all weekend every weekend
on book tv
red hot radio is saul landau's look at
the relationship between culture and
politics during this discussion he talks
about the relationship between president
clinton and monica lewinsky and how
surrounding events generated political
interest in young people mr landau is an
author filmmaker and political activist
and currently chairs the department of
interdisciplinary applied knowledge at
california state polytechnic university
he spoke at modern times bookstore in
san francisco for an hour and ten
minutes
good evening everybody and welcome to
modern times bookstore thank you all for
coming out to brave the elements
it gives us great pleasure this evening
to have with us saul landau
who though he may not know it is very
intertwined with the history of the
store
when we opened 28 years ago in those
carefree nixon years and the height of
the vietnam war
we were much smaller than we were now
but one of our steadiest selling titles
in fact so steady that it almost kept us
afloat the first year was a little
edited volume called to serve the devil
volumes one and two co-edited by mr
landau that kept us going
ten years later during the peak of the
movement against pinochet and chile the
book assassination on embassy row came
out
which was probably wouldn't be
overstated to say that that was
instrumental in
bringing about the international and
starting to bring about the
international delegitimization of the
pinochet regime
and so as we have
maintained ourselves for 28 years as a
progressive resource for the bay area
saul landau in the course of these 28
years has been writing researching film
making
broadcasting on the radio using in fact
every available medium expertly to get
the message of down home radical common
sense across
he has been
awarded various honors emmys honorary
this is and that's which i've lost track
of but needless to say that people in
various positions
to know think the world of his work
and um as do we um the book we have
tonight the new book from common courage
press red hot radio is a collection of
his radio addresses on pacifica radio
and they are just as peppy and just as
energetic and just as controversial and
just as eye-opening in the work he's
doing now as the work he was doing to
help further the movement when we opened
28 years ago so it gives me great
pleasure to present solando
[Applause]
i'll give you a good look at the book
this is for the benefit of the camera of
course
i don't know how many of you heard the
radio show this morning on pacifica
radio
okay well everybody's saying that
they're tired of you know this they're
glad that the
scandal is over
and uh
i don't feel that way at all
i mean what am i gonna write about
um before i get into the serious stuff
um which i'm gonna i'm gonna take you
through the pinochet case tonight
i think a lot of people really don't
understand what it's about
and
not that i can for sure explain it to
you but i'm going to do the best i can
but before i do that i want to
you know come out with a point that i've
been making over and over again
that bill clinton will go down in
history he will have
something on his tombstone and it will
say
bill clinton the education president
well the sex education president
i don't know what else he's done and and
as i said that bill clinton has an
enormous virtue
one outstanding overwhelming virtue
which is that his enemies are far worse
i can't think of another virtue right
off hand but i'm sure during the course
of the evening some will occur to me
but one of the things that got me was
that bill clinton as a result of his
how should i say it philanderings
begat the star report
and the star report
was if you like the libera sexual
liberation of america the right wing the
very people who had been insisting
that the internet be censored you know
these were the people who railed against
smut
don't you love that word smut
these are the people who wanted the
sensor switch on the television who
didn't want
kids to have to read about any of this
stuff
and they flood
the internet
the bookstores everywhere the newspapers
and so
those of you who are parents
who care you know about the kids and if
you're not
uh you know a total far out hippie
in 1999 you care a little bit and so
i
wrote the following radio commentary now
this was
a year ago
well a little more than a year ago in
january of 99 and it's called what do
you tell the kids
i've tried unsuccessfully to get my kid
who's now 11 to read something besides
the comics in the newspaper
and thanks to the sensationalized media
and with assists from bill clinton paula
jones and monica lewinsky
my kid now reads the headlines and
she even reads the lead stories
and this puts all parents into somewhat
of a pickle because what do you say when
the kid says
dad i'm reading the newspapers like you
wanted and now i have some questions
like what's oral sex is that the same as
kissing
oh i didn't even pause i counted well
why aren't you reading about netanyahu
and arafat
the important story is about the middle
east
and a possible breakthrough on israeli
withdrawal from the west bank
the 11 year old made a sour face tell me
dad are they having an affair what does
it mean that monica lewinsky wanted to
earn her presidential knee pads
well maybe the white house has organized
a hockey game for interns i said
but why
why aren't you interested in the pope in
cuba he's going to cuba that's important
it might lead to the lifting of the u.s
embargo if you watch the news in that
mcniel era or whatever they call that
show now you would have deeper knowledge
of the world she yawned
daddy did clinton have sex with other
women is that what he did that was bad
or was it not telling hillary did
hillary forgive him and give him another
chance did hillary have oral sex is she
a lesbian mrs carradine down the block
has sex with the gardener if she was
president would that become news
i felt a little overwhelmed i said look
this is very delicate
you mean what the president did or your
inability to come out and tell me that
monica lewinsky bent down and stop stop
i shouted how come you asked if you
already know
oh dad i watch melrose place in beverly
hills 90210
and those shows are tame compared to the
tv and newspaper headlines over the last
week i think i'll stop watching those
shows and see more news shows because
they're more interesting
you know i saw a one-hour special on
monica that replaced home improvement
it's great to hear grown-ups discuss sex
on tv
with the parents not throwing the census
switch
i was speechless i drove it to school
that morning i turned on rush limbaugh
was having audio orgasms over clinton's
plight and he announced that a newspaper
had taken a poll of washington women
asking would they sleep with bill
clinton and 70 percent answered never
again
my daughter laughed did you understand
that i asked of course dad it was a joke
but you have to admit that bill clinton
has made learning about the birds and
bees a lot more fun
no maybe he has another virtue
all right i want to jump now to
something a little bit more serious
in all serious things you have to start
off with a joke or a little humor
there's some seats up here in front if
you want to come
come up
okay stand out there in the rain i don't
care
and
this is a radio column that i wrote oh
a little over two years ago
and it's called don't call pinochet a
psychopath
it starts with the gags that some of you
might know is two jews in front of a
hitler firing squad
and as the ss sergeant is giving his
command ready aim one of the jews leaps
to his feet and he says stop i have
something very important to say
and the sergeant says all right quick
and the jew says adolf hitler's and no
good s.o.b
and the other jew says what do you have
to make trouble
well
you might not believe it but chileans
were telling this joke about a woman
named gladys marine
and she's chile's communist party chief
she called augusto pinochet
a blackmailer and a psychopath
and when he heard about it
pinochet filed a court action and in
response 40 cops dragged mrs marine from
her car and slammed her into the pokey
and it's all legal
you see because pinochet before chileans
voted him out of office in 1990 made it
a crime to call the country's leaders
nasty names
i don't want to compare pinochet to
hitler you know
hitler lasted only 12 years in power and
pinochet ruled for 17.
and
up until last year he was the commander
of the armed forces
and pinoche thugs only killed tortured
and exiled thousands of people not
millions
but among them was mrs marine's husband
who one day was kidnapped by pinochet
secret police and never seen again
all right so pinochet can't take a joke
but look aspiring leaders from various
countries
worship this guy
former russian strongman alexander
levitt called pinochet his model
pinochet demonstrated very clearly
that 17 years
a brutal military rule could convert
chile from democratic socialism
into free-market democracy
what 17 years of military fascism to
accomplish a transformation like that
before leaving the presidency pinochet
guaranteed the chilean military its
independence
from civilian control
chilean copper sales go directly to
support the armed forces they don't stop
in the civilian government in the
treasury department
and pinochet assured
the military four senate seats including
one for himself for life
when he steps down
chile was hosting in 1996 the ibero
american summit
now and at that summit all of the
governments except for cuba
uh the other governments you know are
all very democratic
and they all practice free market
economics so cuba wasn't invited
now
other than rapidly growing poverty in
most of these countries
the free market model is working just
fine
now chile's ruling politicians
are aspiring and they still are
to become the next nafta partners
and pinochet bothers them a little bit
what are they going to say to the
american congress who are skeptical of
the virtue of these new arrangements and
trade
well
in 1996 a spanish court opened an
investigation of pinochet
and his links with international
terrorism and that's what i'm going to
talk about today
americans recall that his agents
murdered orlando lately
and ronnie moffat in washington dc
september 1976.
spanish lawyers
have contended and the judge accepted
this that pinochet ordered the slaying
as well of other of his enemies abroad
now
as you all know he may be
sent back to spain to face trial this
will be very embarrassing
because you see the ruling coalition of
christian democrats and socialists
are trying to dissuade chileans
from raising issues about pinochet for
example having institutionalized the
military into the nation's political
structure they say they want him back
they want to judge him well
all they've done so far to judge him is
give him amnesty and make him a senator
for life
anyway the joke has come back to chile
it's two chileans now in front of a
pinochet firing squad
gladys marine steps forward and says
pinochet is a no good psychopath and the
other chilean says why do you have to
make trouble
only the other chilean is the president
of chile
come on up front there's some seats here
they don't have to stand
there's about seven seats here
the united states government
has a very uh how should i say it
ambiguous role in this whole
chase situation
as most of you probably know the united
states government from 1970 september
1970
until the coup of september 1973
ordered the destabilization
of the chilean government of the
government of dr salvador allende that
was a government that was elected
it was a government that practiced
democratic procedures
despite what some of the right-wingers
are now saying
it was a democratic government it had a
very good human rights record
the united states government through the
central intelligence agency
began to destabilize that government
that assumes obviously that word itself
that the government was stable to begin
with you don't destabilize something
unless it's stable
and it was done very capriciously as
many
things were done during the cold war
it's what i call epic evil
you know hitler had a vision of epic
evil conquer the world for the make it
all aryan you know
and get rid of the inferior races and
the corrupt jews and all that
epic evil
and the cold war
in a sense was epic evil as well
do anything you have to do in order to
protect the free world from the
communist menace
so in september 1970 shortly after
salvador allende was elected president
of chile by a plurality vote of 36 point
something percent
uh mr donald kendall that name familiar
to you he's the
was president of pepsi cola
he came to visit president nixon
with his friend agustin dooney edwards
who at the time was chile's leading
banker and the publisher
of the right-wing daily called el
mercurio
and mr edwards told mr nixon
in no uncertain terms that allende
is nothing but a communist this is just
a facade for communism
this is cuba's castro this is
brezhnev soviet union this is a straight
out
commie spread of influence into our
hemisphere and you better do something
about it
and nixon called his national security
adviser henry
kissinger and the director of central
intelligence richard helms into the oval
office
and he told them and we know this
because helms took notes and later
testified before a senate committee
where he introduced these notes into the
record
so nixon told helms don't let allende be
inaugurated
and if you do bring him down
do anything you have to do money is no
object make the economy scream these are
all helms's notes
as he read them into the record before
the church committee
in 1974-5
well one of the things that happens
when you undertake an epic evil
like deciding to alter the destiny of
another people which is exactly what
nixon did he's decided what are the
chilean people know they elected this
government we don't like this government
let's get rid of them
so you take what 14 million people and
simply poof decide to change their
destiny because it is in the interest of
the free world
that's what i call epic evil
now let's go back because under the
umbrella of epic evil
you have a phenomenon which the late
hana aren't described as the banality of
evil
when she wrote her book eichmann in
jerusalem
eichmann having been kidnapped by the
israeli secret service and brought to
israel to face trial for the
extermination of three million jews plus
others
and at the trial eichmann was asked why
he hated jews and eichmann said hey jews
i don't hate jews they seem to be nice
people they're
well
well-mannered people they seem to be
very literate and cultured
well but you
gave orders
eliminating three million oh he said and
here comes the banality of evil i was
only following orders
after all what a challenge i faced my
superiors had given me this incredibly
restricted budget to accomplish this
major herculean task of eliminating
millions of people
imagine on such a tiny budget
you have to run them in trains and where
are you going to kill them how are you
going to dispose of the bodies and keep
it secret this was a monumental task and
i took it as a challenge eichmann
testified
and i succeeded on this meager budget i
was able to accomplish the task
my superiors were pleased with the
results
the bureaucrat
the banality of evil all right now jump
ahead
30
years say to chile in 1970.
the word comes down to the cia station
chief
that he's got to get make sure that
allende doesn't get inaugurated he's
been elected september he's due to be
inaugurated in november
how do we stop him well
spread some money around try and bribe
the chilean congress not to ratify the
people's decision this is a tradition in
chile plurality candidate plurality
winner
gets elected president
didn't work
they couldn't bribe enough members of
congress
the step bribe the military
to make a coup
and so the cih station chief went
personally to the house of a general
valenzuela who was at that time the head
of the carabineros the
national police force
and a cia agent and he told him spread
the money around bribe the other
generals make a coup
you'll have another election this time
the right guys will win
well
general valenzuela
didn't succeed
because
the chief of staff general renee
schneider
a strict constitutionalist refused to
take the bribe
he was downright offended that any
chilean military official would offer
him a bribe
now what this meant was
that as soon as jen as president allende
became was inaugurated
general schneider would inform
the president
that there had been an attempt by the
central intelligence agency to bribe the
military to stage a coup
this meant that the cia station chief
would be declared in diplomatic language
png
persona
grata 86 out
this also meant that he would get what
in the cia in washington is known as a
bad fitness report when you screw up in
the cia you get a bad fitness report it
has nothing to do with your physique
it's about your job performance
now
the cia station chief a man how shall we
say it nearing the end of his middle age
had just married a very young and
attractive woman with whom he was madly
in love
and she had told him a note on certain
terms that oh chile was okay there was a
lot of nice people here and the
nightlife was okay among the rich and
powerful
but that she wanted him to succeed and
take his next step to rome or paris or
london
but what she was not going to do under
any circumstances was go with him to
ugabuju or luanda or places like
that forget it
now
if he has a bad fitness report guess
where he's going
you guessed it
to a place where how should i say it
most aspiring
cia officials don't look forward to
going
so what was he going to do
well he decided he had the 50 000 back
that he took from general general
valenzuela in fact he pistol-whipped him
to get it
and he gave it to a bunch of hoodlums
uh who belonged to a fascist
organization called patria libertad
fatherland and freedom
and he told him here's 50 grand knock
off schneider
and
they did
they assassinated general schneider
i was in chile at the time and i said oh
this must be some kind of attempt to
cause a disruption have the military
take over that's what everybody thought
that's what at least it was i thought
and everybody i talked to
but instead of course president allende
came on television and radio
and in his gravest bedside manner
he assured the chilean population that
he was in charge order would reign
law would prevail
his popularity rating soared he hit 70
percent from a 36.4
all of a sudden he shot up allende was
the doctor in charge
but general schneider wasn't there to
tell president allende
about the cia coup
all right that's how it began the
destabilization campaign begins in blood
and it continues in blood for three
years there's strikes in crucial sectors
trying to paralyze the
economy there were rumor campaigns i
remember sitting in the bar
of the carrera sheraton
one night
and a an american
sidles up to me says he's a businessman
and did i know that allende had syphilis
no i said not only that he's a
homosexual who takes his orders from
castro and the russians are shipping
thousands of tanks into chile
no kidding i said
they're going to just sort of sneak them
in yep he said that's right and they're
going to get lots of arms and give them
to the million workers or so and train
them in secret oh quite a trick i said
every night i would go into the bar at
the carrera sheridan i would hear rumors
like this right allende has been sent to
the insane asylum all kinds of stuff
every day in the newspapers you would
read these rumors published on the front
page you would hear them on the radio
read them in the magazines
since allende never censored the press
and most of it was controlled by the
right wing these rumors mostly went
unanswered
nevertheless
in 1972 when the next
non-presidential elections were held
allende's plurality his coalition is
socialist coalition
rose from
36.5 or six up past 40 percent
despite the fact that hardship was
increasing but hardship was increasing
at the same time that poor kids were
getting powdered milk for the first time
subsidized by the government
the workers understood in chile that it
was their government
and in 1973 as the destabilization
effort intensified
elections were held again off-year
elections and this time the coalition's
vote tally rose to 44 percent
as the destabilization effort grew more
and more critical allende decided to
call a plebiscite yes or no his
government would continue or it would
not continue
and the date scheduled for the
plebiscite was the 18th of september
chilean independence day
on september 11th
united states navy ships sailed along
the coast of chile and stopped by the
port of valparaiso
on quote routine maneuvers
the routine maneuvers uh
i discovered rel relatively recently
were designed
uh
so that the united states navy spy ships
could monitor the communications going
on at all of the chilean military bases
the coup was planned to coincide with
these maneuvers so that the coup makers
would know if any of the military units
wanted to remain loyal to allende
and therefore could send a counter force
to suppress them
the coup took place in the morning of
september 11th allende grabbed a gun and
told his cabinet and his advisors and
staff if you want to stay and fight it
out and die
that's your choice otherwise you better
leave
a lot of them stayed some of them left
the chilean air force flew hawker hunter
fighter bombers that fired rockets into
the windows with amazing precision
this is long before the gulf war
amazing precision right into the windows
of the moneta the presidential palace
the tanks surrounded it fired their
cannons
allende died
and pinochet took over
well there are two stories one is that
he committed suicide that's the story
that's accepted even by his uh
some of his socialist
colleagues the other story which i got
ironically from the fbi
was that he was killed in battle
by two of the raiders who were sent in
to storm the palace
uh and who were rewarded by the way with
a trip to the united states for their
valor
this story was told to an fbi agent by
the two men who were decorated for
shooting allende
but shortly after their medals were
taken away and the general in charge
told him we're changing the story he
committed suicide
i personally believe that they killed
him
but let's not get into that let's go on
with the story because from september
11th
1973
until march of 1990 pinochet reigns
he is first the head of a military junta
and then he makes himself president of
the republic
he even rewrites the constitution in the
first months
the constitution is shredded
congress is closed the press is shut
down
pinochet's stormtroopers visit every
library and every university
and they find every book with the word
marx whether it's carl or groucho and
they burn it
they impose a curfew and they begin to
arrest people without
warrants without charges and they begin
a systematic and routine torture
of all people considered to be left-wing
now where did they get all the names of
these left-wingers who had collected all
of the names of the socialists the
communists the mir the social democrats
the left-wing christians
thank you
thank you watson
the cia had collected these names
and gave them to the new military
government
so that they could look for them find
them torture them extract information
from them
and in many cases
kill or later on disappear them
disappearance was a new form
of behavior of the chilean secret police
and this was meant to thwart human
rights monitors
somebody is walking along the street and
a car pulls up four guys in plain
clothes jump out grab the guy and throw
him in the car
that's it he's never seen again
the guy's wife goes to the police
station says people saw my husband being
arrested
there's no arrest record here madam
take a look
no indication your husband was arrested
no record
thousands of people were disappeared
not only in chile and argentina as well
and in other places
the chilean government came up with a an
official report that 3 000 almost 3 200
people were officially listed as as
victims
of pinochet
now one of the things he did and i'll go
into some detail with you because i
think it's an interesting story and it
indicates what he was about
pinochet led
an operation called condor
named after that giant vulture that
flies high in the andes
condor was an association of six
intelligence agencies
in latin america
chile was condor one because it was the
key organizer there was argentina
uruguay
brazil paraguay
and bolivia
and what these organizations did the
different secret police agencies
they would share information on each
other's dissidents living in those
societies so if a chilean exile was
living in argentina the argentine secret
police would monitor his activities and
report back to chile through a computer
provided by
the cia
excuse me
so monitoring
each other's dissidents was one phase of
condor the second phase is when these
dissidents were thought to
become serious enemies
of whatever regime
condor
arranged for sanctions
and these sanctions meant of course
assassination
now the first chilean condor victim that
we know of was killed about one year
after the coup and it was the former
chief of staff the man who replaced
schneider also who refused to be bribed
general carlos pratz
pratz had exiled himself and was living
with his wife in buenos aires
one evening as he drove home into
entering his the garage in the apartment
building where he lived
a couple of argentine
secret police agents
pushed some buttons on a remote control
detonator and general pratt and his wife
were blown literally nine stories high
this was a condor hit
that is the chilean's agents had come
over from santiago worked with the
argentine secret police made the bomb
placed the bomb under the car and then
the chilean agents left and the
argentines pressed the button
we know about this because the fbi
discovered it because the same man who
eventually is involved in the lately
case was also the man involved in the
pratt's case
one year later
bernardo leighton and his wife
bernardo layton is a
exiled christian democratic politician
he and his wife are walking 10 o'clock
in the evening down a roam street in
italy
and a gunman comes up behind them and
pumps a bullet into each one of their
skulls from behind
they were badly wounded and never really
recovered fully but didn't die
one year later
in washington dc september 21st 1976
orlando la talier another former defense
minister
is driving
on the way to work down massachusetts
avenue what's called embassy row
la taliera was the last defense minister
in the allende government
he like all the other cabinet members
were were arrested sent to a
concentration camp in dawson island near
the south pole
where he served a year and then through
international pressure he was released
he came to washington to work with me at
the institute for policy studies
lately are
enroute to work
next to him in the car
was ronnie moffat
a young american colleague also working
at the institute for policy studies
and in the back seat
was her husband michael moffatt who was
also employed by ips
well michael moffatt describes
hearing a very loud hiss and seeing a
very bright white light
in the car
and smelling this incredibly accurate
odor
and
within two seconds
the door had blown off the back of the
car and michael moffatt went flying out
of the car
and when he shook his head and saw what
had happened he saw his wife staggering
to the curb and somebody helping her and
he went to the car to help lately here
and he discovered lately had no legs
that the explosion had blown his legs
off
and at that time michael moffatt
screamed fascist dina pinochet
as the secret service agent who raced
over not knowing what was going on took
one look at lately air and lost his
breakfast
now the fbi tracked
the killers in this case and they
tracked it
to the head to the top of the chilean
government
they tracked it to the head of the
secret police
at that time colonel manuel contreras
and the fbi began to investigate now
this is something you see that these
little nuances that dictators like
pinochet don't quite understand that the
very government that had helped him make
the coup in 1973
now could come
to track
just because he killed a couple of
people in washington dc
he didn't understand that there were
certain limits there were certain
nuances in american support
it didn't cover everything
that the f very fbi by the way that had
helped him track down his own leftists
the very agent
indeed who had helped
his secret police locate certain
left wingers
now was after him
because he had done a real no-no he had
murdered in washington d.c
now pinochet is on trial and one of the
charges he faces is international
terrorism
and as i have explained to you he is an
international serial killer
pratt's leighton lately here and the fbi
discovered
that the very man who had made the bomb
that killed pratt and that killed la
talier and moffat
had also planned to assassinate the
entire exiled leadership of allende's
socialist coalition when they were
meeting in mexico luckily he didn't get
it all together in time
he had also been given orders to
assassinate other chileans living in
europe in fact the c i a found out and
stopped one in france and one in spain
this is an international serial killer
now the united states
having tracked
the murders of lately and murders of
lately and moffat to the head of the
secret police stopped short they didn't
go after pinochet
although they tried to get him out of
power they
moved to
have him hold elections and so on
knowing that he would lose
and now that he's being charged by a
spanish court
and being detained in england
the united states government is in
somewhat
not of a dilemma but of a pickle
what does attorney general reno do
does she reopen the case
because murder cases
aren't closed
and indict pinochet
she has ample reason to do so two of the
fbi agents who directed that
investigation have declared publicly
that it is
inconceivable
their words
that pinochet was unaware and didn't
authorize this he had to have authorized
that the fbi agent said based on their
investigation
the former prosecutor who
prosecuted one of the cases in
washington dc with the where the
low-level people were involved
also said the same thing and testified
before the spanish judge to that effect
the united states has
thousands and thousands of classified
files
some of which implicate pinochet some of
which for example a defense intelligence
agency memo which i happen to see
in an unauthorized way
declared and i don't think this is a
coincidence
that it is inconceivable the the word in
the memo that pinochet did not authorize
these murders
so attorney general reno could do two
things
she could indict pinochet for conspiracy
to assassinate orlando lately and ronnie
moffat and demand that chile extradite
him
assuming that he sent back to chile or
she could
turn over all of the declassified files
to the spanish magistrate
when pinochet hopefully will go on trial
in spain and that's where we are today
this has come full circle
the united states has three problems
one is it has very close political and
economic ties
with the government of president frey
the christian democrat
secondly the united states is going to
find out
or american public will find out the
world will find out what many people who
are informed already know that the
united states was complicit
in destabilizing the allende government
and bringing pinochet to power and third
and most damaging
that the united states was complicit in
some of the human rights violations that
ensued under the pinochet regime
i trust attorney general reno will do
the right thing i think she is an
honorable person and an honorable woman
i will leave it at that
let me
wrap up this
the chilean
the whole chilean thing was
so sordid and so depressing to many
people
here was an attempt to make
a democratic socialist
country
out of a democrat with a democratically
elected government
it is chewed armed struggle
it was open
it allowed for civil liberties
all of the things that we like in this
country were practiced by allende
and it was brutally overthrown
in the name of
protecting the free world a capricious
move
which i classify as epic evil
and afterwards a lot of banel evil
happened
the chileans
finally have a chance
to do something to make it right
for 17 no more than that now from 1973
to 1999
or 98 anyway
pinochet has dictated their lives
for 17 years he told them what they
could and could not to do
he told them when they could go on the
street and when they couldn't go in the
street what they could say and what they
couldn't say
and after he was gone there was an
announcement that there would be
reconciliation
what kind of reconciliation is it
when
the victims have to accept their fate
and those and the victimizers
pay no penalty at all
what kind of reconciliation is that when
the murderers and the torturers
and the brutes walk free
and the victims are told it's
reconciliation you have to forgive they
have to do nothing and you have to
forgive
that's bs reconciliation
well now for the first time
there may be real reconciliation
because pinochet's case opens the
possibility
for other human rights cases
all over the world
there's a new word now
in the language everywhere
my friend jennifer harberry
whose husband was murdered
by
the guatemalan military has initiated a
case in costa rica
to bring some of the murderers to trial
and one of the people she subpoenaed a
military official she met in the street
in guatemala and she said are you
planning to come to testify
in the trial answering the subpoena
and the man said to her only if you
promise you won't pinot jamie
and imagine what it is it's the first
punishment
the first
general pinochet in october of 1998
flew to london where he flew every year
as he got off the plane a red carpet was
unraveled
unfurled excuse me
and he
and he walked down as a as an honor
dignitary
he went shopping at harrods in the eight
of the finest restaurants and then he
went to visit his dear friend
mrs thatcher to have tea with her
and they chatted pleasantly
and after he finished that he went into
a private exclusive clinic
to have a little back surgery to adjust
a disc
and when he was coming out of the
anaesthetic he looked up and there was
this strange man standing above him
who announced that he was from scotland
yard
and that
general pinochet was being detained
and could not leave england
how do you like that when you were
coming out of your anesthetic huh that's
pretty good for an 82 year old guy i
figured he'd gotten away with it
because the chileans i mean he had
dictated amnesty for himself that's a
very weird way i didn't know that you
could
you know proclaim amnesty for yourself
so i absolve myself of all the crimes
that i might have committed for 17 years
it's a pretty good trick
he made himself a senator for life which
would give him further protection in
case people like mrs marine would try to
sue him
senator vitalicio sounds very nice in
spanish doesn't it
senator for life well there he is he's
been detained since october
this is a change in human rights law
a lot of people you know who have
committed human rights violations might
have changed their travel plan since
then
but it gives an opportunity i think for
people all over the world to know that
maybe a measure of justice
is possible
i say a measure of justice not justice
because once
somebody is dead or terribly tortured
there can't be justice anymore but a
small measure of justice
anyway well let me stop it right there
and open up for questions and tell you
that you'll find other stuff in the book
that will uh relate to what i've been
saying the book is called red hot radio
i had to check the title here
sex violence and politics at the end of
the american century
and there's two other books on sale um
with it
one is how many of you read spanish
anybody here
it's called
the
the vindication and the testimony of
orlando la tallier it's a book i wrote
with joanne garces the spanish lawyer
who initiated the complaints against
pinochet in madrid
and he is the lawyer who represents
the families of the victims
and with it you will get a tape of
orlando la tellier's last letter he used
to write letters on cassettes he would
dictate them
and it's his description of the last two
weeks which he was defense minister
describing in great detail
all of the events that took place
during those last weeks before allende
was overthrown it's quite a document so
that book is out there as well as my
first volume called hot air
having said that let me open this up for
questions
a pickle is sour or half sour
a dilemma is totally unacceptable
alternative to the same problem
yes enough about chile what do you think
we
so called left in the united states
could be doing right now
to improve things
well i think to improve things you have
to get into politics
you have to work at it
you have to work out in a local level
and
every four years you get a chance to do
national stuff and there's also national
campaigns
let's say one thing right now
president
clinton has asked for a huge increase in
the military budget
and congress is even asking for a bigger
increase
now this to me sounds a little absurd
the cold war is about a decade dead
we have no enemies out there that we can
point to that are threatening our
security
anybody
okay
so why do we need and this is a senator
asked one of the pentagon generals
general you know what do we need
what do you need more money for
and the general sat back in his chair
and said senator
it's a dangerous world out there
adam and eve could have said that
can you imagine adam and eve asking for
a 300 billion dollar defense budget
because it's a dangerous world out there
what kind of an answer is that
oh well the general said there's
terrorists out there
what is the us military got to guys who
blow up the oklahoma federal building
what what relationship have they got
except that they trained them
all right that's one area that's really
important that's a national that's an
international area
you know every day people can write
letters can make phone calls can send
emails can send faxes
on all of these issues and cumulatively
they count
if general reno receives a
email or a letter or a phone call saying
indict pinochet you have the evidence
and the same information is sent to
senators feinstein and boxer from
california
and the local members of congress all of
them are going to weigh in on this
that counts
that's old-fashioned politics
the other is to find candidates who are
our candidates
you know somebody asked me uh
you know would i support ron daniels in
the year 2000 for president
and uh
or ralph nader and i said well if ralph
nader ran for president i would
absolutely support him
his name was on the ballot but he really
wasn't running last time
if he really ran for president i would
drop everything and support him
and there are other people that's how
you build it but you have to
keep at it you have to say to yourself i
think
that politics shouldn't be seen as
something grim
that politics should be seen not just as
an obligation that i have to do
but something that you can have a lot of
fun at
you know
some of the people here are old enough
to remember the 1960s
when politics went along with sex drugs
and rock and roll well we still have
rock and roll
and
politics can and should be fun you meet
a lot of people and it's a lot more
interesting than watching television
so there's lots of things to do and you
know you win right and then you have to
defend those rights how long ago did
women
win the
right to have choice and roe versus wade
and every day they have to fight to keep
that right
i tell my students at the university
how come you're allowed to live in co-ed
dorms now
they all shrug their shoulders i see you
have that because you students 30 years
ago won that right
when i was a student
if a man was in a woman's dorm after 9
pm the man was expelled
wasn't even suspended didn't even get a
hearing
and now people live in coed dorms what a
change and how come
because people got into politics
and they won those rights when i was a
student i had to take rotc
i didn't have a choice i could not
graduate
from the university of wisconsin
if i did not complete two years of rotc
did you picture me in the military
police
yes i was two years in the military
police first
honest
and now kids don't have to take
compulsory rotc because students
demonstrate it against
and won
and so on
so
you know and as long as you don't count
the ultimate success as the
reason for your being in politics and
i'll end it with this my late great
friend paul jacobs
had fought a tremendous battle
against
the nuclear agencies against
who i call the nuclear gang
and he had demonstrated in a series of
report
reports which he had written for
magazines
that the atomic energy commission at
that time
what they were known was simply lying to
the public about the dangers of
low-level radiation
and on one of his investigative forays
he probably inhaled a particle a
radioactive particle lodged in his lung
and gave him lung cancer i think that
and he thought that his doctors thought
that because he didn't smoke
and as he was dying
i asked him the question paul you know
now you're
you know i didn't quite say you're about
to kick the bucket
but i said you know do you think
what you did was worth it
and he said look
the talmud says that
you don't have to finish the job
but that doesn't free you from playing
your part
so while you're here in the world you
play your part
then you know what you'll have a much
richer
and more interesting life than people
who don't play their part
yes
you know those who would have been
destroyed but they instead took all the
families and sent them somewhere in that
america government
and maintained their houses and
established
the other government some of them are
now living in florida all right
keeps their houses um
that anyway haiti's dropped out so i
wonder what do you think about that kind
of politics is that
and what um
do you know what's going on
well
let me try to refine what i think u.s
policy is
it's not just anti-communist
u.s policy especially toward latin
america
has been a policy of punishing people
who are disobedient
and these people usually are on the left
but not always i mean general noriega
you wouldn't call a left winger would
you
but he was disobedient he wouldn't help
he was he was ordered to obey
uh on our
on our contra war and he didn't think
that was a good thing so he was punished
the president of brazil in 1964 went on
some nationalist kick and he was
punished
in the dominican republic
there was a dictator named trujillo
who was stepping out of line and he was
punished the cia tried to assassinate
him he probably did
so
and then general pinoche as soon as he
became disobedient he was nudged out of
the presidency with u.s
support
now the guys in haiti
were loyal up to a point and then they
started to become disobedient and so
they were moved out as well
well the united states doesn't want to
throw them out they don't want to you
don't want to set a bad example
or people won't be up you know
won't be our agents again
that's the only thing i can think of
you know it's a very strange empire we
have
it's an empire that's not wrecked
doesn't recognize itself as an empire
if you walk up to an american citizen
you say hey what do you think of the
empire today
what are you talking about what empire
we don't have an empire it's a republic
well that's true it is a republic and
it's an empire well which one is which
an empire the british empire said we are
the british empire we are very proud and
the french empires worldwide and so on
all these empires
proudly proclaim themselves as empires
yeah empire us
perish to thought we're defending
democracy we're stopping communism we're
doing something else we're not an empire
how do you explain 40 50 bases abroad
well
you never know when they're needed
the united states
freely intervene anywhere in the world
that it wanted until the vietnam war and
then we learned a very
serious lesson
after vietnam you don't fight anybody
who can fight back
that was the lesson one the second
lesson is don't let the media run wild
over there you know
you know what the media needs is
pictures you give them the pictures
they're happy
as long as they have pictures there's
the gulf war look at these smart bombs
wow wow
bombs hitting the targets you can see
the pentagon's giving them all these
pictures you're looking at wow this is
like a you know
a video game looks pretty good
uh orton grenada
they were given the pictures
they weren't given enough pictures in
grenada so they learned that less you
had to give them more pictures
because with television you it doesn't
happen if you don't see it so you didn't
see it didn't happen
do you have to have a picture
and so the pentagon now provides the
pictures
tells the correspondence what is
happening you know
what can i say the media you ask what
can be done
more independent media or try and force
the media to do its job
you know years ago there was a story
i mean
when i listen to kpfa
or any of the pacifica stations and i
hear the news i said well i didn't
realize that
it was a story today about how the
loggers
are ripping off the public land and
using our taxpayers money uh to do so so
why didn't why don't the san francisco
chronicle and or cbs or nbc or cnn
handle those stories
you know and when a war the president
announces that the terrorists have uh uh
a factory in sudan that's making
serious weapons of mass destruction
and they bombed that factory
and months later so a little story leaks
out well so they weren't so they weren't
manufacturing weapons of mass
destruction
or we're going to punish osama bin laden
and you fire 400 cruise missiles into
the caves of afghanistan
and the press
dutifully reports it
there's a story you know that winston
churchill was once about to announce a
very unpopular policy
and one of his aides said to him sir
winston
don't you think you'd better whip the
press into line first
and churchill replied he says my dear
boy
as far as i can recall sheep don't need
whipping
well
get on the media i mean that's another
thing you can do people are educated
focus report is to ask critical
questions stop taking their stories from
official sources or so-called background
briefing
uh i think i saw your name associated
with the
move to impeach clinton for the right
reasons
you didn't
i don't think clinton should be
impeached i think as soon as he steps
down from the presidency he should be
tried as a war criminal
but i don't think he should be impeached
i don't think he's committed an
impeachable offense i think he has
committed crimes against humanity
bombing iraq
is criminal
but i'm not sure it's an impeachable
offense the american public voted for
this jerk twice
right they knew he was a liar they knew
he was a philanderer
and the american public
supports this but you know if we're
going to enforce the law let's enforce
the law but let's not make another
circus i mean although i must admit i
enjoyed this circus
so no i don't in favor of impeaching him
but i do favor
uh on the day he steps down trying him
as a war criminal
are
simply because of the initial phase of
the destabilization project
now are there any policies that we do
now with certain countries that are
maybe a more updated version of that
that scare you that you see
no i don't think the united states does
that anymore doesn't have to do that
you understand that
it's a very good question you asked
during the cold war
the united states destabilized or
overthrew other governments
and the united states won the key
political victories that led to what is
now called globalization
the political victories understand the
defeat of communism the fall of soviet
socialism tremendous victory the
conversion of third world nationalist
governments into free market
so-called democracies
these were incredible political
victories and third the complete
dismantling of the welfare state
three immense political victories that
open the world to the globalizers
whatever that word means to you
but
what politics are left
i mean try to analyze
where are the politics today people say
well let's get a let's get off of this
monica lewinsky impeachment stuff and
get down to the serious issues which are
come on let's hear the issues that
congress wants to discuss
education who is against education
anybody here against education thank you
what else social security anybody here
against social security
what's wrong with social security it's
threatened in the year 2030
crap
what else can i hear the other political
issues
health care anybody against health care
anybody see a
glimmer of possibility of getting a
national health system
anybody here any of these
sterling politicians any of the
presidential candidates bill bradley
al gore
he would be a great president actually
i'm convinced if he was running for the
slow talkers of america
which candidates are talking about that
stuff well maybe jesse jackson will run
and he'll raise those issues or maybe
ralph nader will run again he'll raise
those issues but you've got to raise him
with your members of congress and with
your senators those are issues we need a
national
health care system we need a fair
taxation system which taxes the rich and
the corporations and gives a poor break
you know
because ever since ronald reagan has
been this
theme in america the poor had their
chance and they blew it okay they're
gone
you know gore vidal said a wonderful
thing he said
american democratic system is the
greatest system yet
invented for the poor to excuse me for
the rich to wage an unending war against
the poor successfully
we've got to turn it around
so what issues are going to raise now
where's the politics
the united states is an empire now
chooses where it will intervene it will
not intervene anywhere where you can
lose any substantial number of troops
because the public doesn't want that
we're not an empire we don't go around
the world
saving kosovo or somalia or wherever
we intervene only where it's prudent
where there's good photo ops good
publicity and so on
this is a unique empire
it has no charter there's no imperial
charter here
we act as if we're a republican
[Music]
which is with new york city and i mean
this is like a huge quarter
i have an acquaintance that works it's
like tell me that you know these are
like
of like a um all the walls around the
temple there like a sandwich or a
steel in the middle and concrete on the
side and
and i'm wondering if are they getting
ready for something in the future or
this is like
something that was being built where all
the problems
yes when it was built they were
expecting to be attacked
remember the assault on the u.s embassy
in saigon
how many of you remember that one
well
that that put an indelible
blueprint into the mind of the state
department security experts and they
were now going to design embassies that
couldn't be attacked
i mean this thing was even
still being built in 1994 and you know
the peace treaties were
like signed back in 1992
and uh well the attitude the attitude is
that you know after all we've done for
the rest of the world they're so damn
ungrateful
and uh you never know when they're going
to turn on us
that's basically the mentality yes in
the
back good so uh i feel a little
frustrated me too
but one of the things that
you responded to you say well take on
the media i find that
um that's
way out of the question because you have
now consolidation of the media i don't
talk to reporters
not as much as you do tell me that i
can't get a story in or that you know my
editor is not going through that
anywhere and i don't see any any
penetration in that sort of like a
unilateral wiping out of everything
uh
i can't live totally on the negative
thing so i have a little optimism but i
have a frustration with what about that
had it all my life with the left with
that some separate then that is that we
don't know how to really organize and i
know i'm going to insult many people in
this room and probably including myself
and the thing that we really have not
developed those techniques of being able
to go myself and the thing that we
really have not developed those
techniques of being able to go and talk
to people
and to mobilize and that kind of thing
we're good for going out for rallies
where ghosts were putting things that
doesn't talk to people and we do have an
issue with health care and i know i
talked to everybody i've talked to every
taxi cab driver bus driver anywheres
that people are mobilized by that and
where are we
in that we're not moving on that and
that makes me feel very frustrated
because i don't know without my comrades
doing something what to do about that
and i lay it out to you perhaps
well it sounds like you could give a
course in it and i would take that
course
and i think all the people excuse me all
the people in the room
uh should find out tell me your name
over the years i recognize you june even
without my glasses
that if you go and
study with dr june fisher you will get a
wonderful course in how to organize and
how to be a great human being too
thank you all for coming and i'll be
glad to sign the books for you
[Applause]
common courage press publishes red hot
radio there online at common courage
press dot com mr landau is an author
filmmaker and political activist and can
be heard on the pacifica radio network
as